there's a semblance of calm on the
streets of the ethiopian capital ali
sababa but this is a city fearing the
prelude to a storm which is gathering on
its doorstep
draped in the colors of the ethiopian
flag ephraim solomon popularly known as
ethiopia's flagman is out preaching
patriotism to a nation divided by
conflict
in these uncertain times of conflict
ephraim preaches about unity and an end
to the deeply entrained tribalism in
ethiopia
i have not had good sleep for the past
three months i keep worrying about the
conflict i therefore decided to do my
bit and preach about cohesion to my
people the ethiopian government insists
the capital and its bustling markets are
safe it has also been rallying residents
to take up arms as a last-ditch defense
against the rebels from tigray who say
they have every intention to match onto
the capital
addis ababa is safe the government has
stepped up security and i don't think
those rebels will have any chance
reaching here
the tigray conflict had a huge impact on
ethiopia's economy which until now was
one of the fastest growing in africa
this is ethiopia's wall street the heart
of adi sababa's business district
traders say the conflict in tigray and
the covet 19 pandemic have had a
devastating effect on businesses here
it's not clear how much the war has cost
but economic analysts predict that
ethiopia's defense expenditure is set to
rise to 502 million dollars
up from 460 million last year
overall economic growth is also set to
significantly reduce from six percent
last year to just two percent this year
the lowest in more than two decades
according to the international monetary
fund
just two years ago ethiopian prime
minister abi ahmed was praised by the
international community he was awarded
the nobel peace prize for ending the
conflict with neighboring eritrea
but his time in office has been largely
defined by conflict his government
declared a state of emergency as the
rebels made significant advances towards
addis ababa
many residents of the capital have
answered the call to arms
and marched to the front lines
many others however feel the
government's treatment of tigran
citizens many of whom have been rounded
up and detained has been unacceptable
i believe our government should stop
targeting people just because of their
ethnicity the government must
differentiate between the tigrans who
are fighting it and the vast majority of
tigrans who are peace-loving citizens of
ethiopia
tens of thousands have already fled the
conflict but this is the tip of what
could be a bigger crisis with a
population of about
million people a full-scale civil war in
ethiopia could easily become the biggest
humanitarian crisis
in decades
muhammad al-jazeera
by ethiopia